après avoir reçu des seringues
ensanglantés dans ma boîte aux lettres
cache-toi il vaut mieux pour ta sécurité
pédée va crever et disparaître à tout
jamais j'ai beau envoyer ça au juge
d'instruction leur montrer ce qui se
passe en fait je pense qu'il faut que je
me suicide pour que
les choses avancent pas ça je pense à il
y a une influenceuse là qui s'est donné
la mort et que elle n'a pas supporté en
fait la lenteur judiciaire elle s'est
suicidée étrangement tous ces accéléré
quand elle est morte donc en fait oui
c'est ce que je dis à chaque fois dans
les tribunaux il faut se [ __ ] en l'air
pour que les choses bougent parce que
personne n'en a rien à [ __ ] va leur
donner raison en faisant ça je sais et
dieu merci j'ai peur de la mort et je ne
me suiciderai pas se retrouver en fait
vous voyez accusé de choses terribles le
jeremstarget c'est ça en fait c'est une
histoire qui n'était pas la mienne il
faut continuer à témoigner comme ça ce
que je regrette c'est mon passé ça c'est
certain parce que j'ai moi-même
contribué à un système où je pouvais
participer à des vagues de harcèlement
envers certains candidats télé-réalité
j'y allais avec le dos de la cuillère et
j'ai été vraiment un vrai connard par le
passé présente vraiment très sincèrement
mes excuses aux gens que j'ai blessé